es la reunión en la que todo occidente
tenía puesta su atención los máximos
diplomáticos de eeuu y rusia anthony
blinken y sérguei lávrov se reunieron
para intentar desde escalar las
tensiones en torno a ucrania
nuestro objetivo es determinar si rusia
está preparada para tomar un camino
diplomático de otros pasos necesarios
para reducir la escalada de la situación
en ucrania
en última instancia resolver nuestras
diferencias las conversaciones de hoy
con el señor lávrov fueron francas y
sustanciales
rusia tiene cientos de tropas
desplegadas en ucrania y ha comenzado
entrenamientos militares en su frontera
con belarús algo que ha aumentado las
tensiones que eeuu quiere rebajar
diplomáticamente pero la condición de
rusia es clara quieren una respuesta a
su propuesta de seguridad que incluye la
desmovilización de las tropas de la otan
en sus zonas de influencia para retomar
el diálogo
rusia nunca ni una sola vez mediante sus
representantes oficiales ha amenazado a
la gente ucraniana
como les he dicho este no es el fin de
las discusiones la semana que viene como
antony blinken ha dicho en varias
ocasiones recibiremos una respuesta por
escrito
eeuu también exigió pruebas de que rusia
no planea una invasión a ucrania una
confirmación que también esperan a los
militares ucranianos desplegados en la
frontera fusionada depende de la gente
común solo los políticos lo pueden
resolver por supuesto no quiero que esto
escale una guerra tras la confirmación
de blinken se espera que rusia y eeuu
retome en las conversaciones sobre las
propuestas de seguridad de moscú en
febrero